[Music]
now professor tim spector
is an epidemiologist his company zoe or
zoe
has been behind the covert symptoms app
developed by king's college london
which collects its own data from
millions of people self-reporting
the symptoms every day allowing
professor spector's team
to follow a a pretty up-to-date picture
of the infection around the country
professor welcome
to spectator tv i know it's a busy time
of the year so we're grateful
to get your time tell us a bit more
about the work that is uh
done at zoe with the colvin symptoms app
we launched on the 24th of march uh the
first day of lockdown
and we were about the only game in town
the only
app that was out there that was able to
gather data on uh people and within
24 hours we had a million downloads and
now have
four million subscribers of which about
one million
are giving us uh near daily reports and
this
combined with um getting people when
they get symptoms tested
uh rapidly uh allows us to get a running
uh or so in real time
estimates of what's going on around the
country in a way that
the the other systems don't we we do
track the ons study
the government's uh official survey that
goes into households
so we get very similar estimates but
we're normally about four or five days
ahead of them
tell me what what divergences do you see
if there are divergences between the
data you are
garnering and the official government
data that we tend to
look at either on the daily cases and
deaths cases or in the ons figures
and so on what are the differences well
we
very few differences with the ons data
but we do see differences with the
confirmed cases
so the problem with the confirmed cases
is
that total goes up and down somewhat
erratically
uh because there's no denominator
there's no uh
fixed number of tests they do and they
look at the the percentages because
once an outbreak starts then more people
get tested people get nervous
and they find more cases so um i think
at the moment
using just these confirmed cases which
is nice for media headlines and
as like deaths doesn't give the full
picture and often exaggerates
rapid changes uh going up or down and so
i think our data on the ons is a better
guide to actually what's happening
and doesn't show as bleaker picture as
often is portrayed with the deaths and
the confirmed cases
um so you know the ideas of these
massive surges in london
um aren't borne out by our data we are
seeing
increases which are worrying but we're
not seeing increases in the over 60s
we're recording hospital admissions
because we were told by the government
that
these five parameters to assess tears
would be transparent and given out to
everybody but that hasn't materialized
so we're
on the app providing that to users and
anyone who logs into our app
gets the full report so we're trying to
be more transparent so people we believe
people will act
responsibly if they're given the data
and at the moment
they're not being given the data they're
just being given a bit of a stick
and so that's uh generally what
we're we're we're up against and i and
looking at our data
over the last few months we were able to
look at certain patterns
and realize that you know certain
decisions about lockdowns etc
um or welsh fire breaks you know
uh have actually failed or were taken
prematurely as katie mentioned earlier
that
sometimes these big decisions are taken
too early without the latest data
and by the time they find out
everything's changed and then
you know the data are retrofitted to to
go with that decision
so um i think you need to look at all
the data
and get also get the most up-to-date
data i think is really important because
there are
huge differences across the country and
we talk about it as if there's only one
you know these massive regions or we're
all
the uk is one thing but there are we're
predicting
by christmas there'll be tenfold
differences across the country
in how likely your local bubble is to
have covered and
you know and that's should make and
having one rule for everybody
uh when there's a ten times different
rate of infection uh to me
doesn't make much sense and we do need a
perhaps a more local regional way of
doing this
although i understand it's difficult
politically that's fascinating let me
ask you a question about what your data
can tell us about the second wave
but also a question about now to begin
with the second wave
what does i mean if we look at the
government data we listen to the
politicians and the scientific advisors
around them
i think a lot of us have been quite
surprised by the scale of the second
wave
and by the virulence and by the
longevity of it
um but we're surprised from a position
of no expertise
uh what does your data tell us
about how do you see the second wave
through your data
we're seeing that if we take the uk as a
whole
we are seeing it so far is
less causing less problems than the
first wave
it's affecting young people more than
old people
it's causing less hospitalizations we're
not seeing
uh with a few exceptions of a few trusts
we're not seeing
most hospitals being overrun and
we're seeing big differences between
areas that we didn't see as much
in the first wave possibly because of
uh areas that hit very badly in the
first wave like central london
uh not having as much problem in the
second wave because of
some relative immunity so it's it's a
different picture
but uh as we've seen the thing here is
we're seeing that as these restrictions
have been
relaxed uh strengthened and relaxed very
quickly which we didn't happen in the
first wave
we're seeing these major rebounds like
we're seeing in wales where
it looks like post fire break things are
twice as bad as they were
before we think this is related to
people's behavior who
you know knowing that we have this
extraordinary position in this country
where we announce
some new tier system coming in uh and
all the pubs will shut in three days
time
and get surprised that people go out and
meet their mates
um in the next few days and then we lock
them down for again
and we see these very much behavioral
effects that i don't think have been
taken into account so
um looking at the data we'd say it's a
big mistake to keep
turning these screws up and down and
looking at the the first bit of the
second wave it looks like the
uh decision to have a national lockdown
wasn't really justified anyway
because it was coming down in the north
already before that
at quite a fast rate so i think you know
it's easy
with retrospect to look at this and i
think it's a really tricky problem for
government
but i think we do have the data to
enable us to learn lessons going forward
and i think
it would be not to keep turning the tap
on and off it would be to actually
have some regulations until easter that
makes sense
and give people this local information
about what's going on in their hospital
what the rates are
you know what their real risk is and i
think that's
where we're hoping to do that with our
with the zoe app
you would see what you're saying
professor is the the government
needs better data more reliable data on
which to base its decisions
and once it's based decisions on that
more the kind of more reliable the data
you're talking about
there should then should be an element
of consistency
uh in in whatever lockdown or
restrictions
there's going to be that that we should
abandon this
what we've called here on spectator tv
the sort of hokey cookie of in and out
shaken all about would that be a fair
summary of what you're saying
yeah absolutely and i think we have to
also set you know we have to set some
idea what the actual
achieve what's the aim what is the
outcome here
is it just to stop levels you know as
the media calls it surging and everyone
gets in a panic
or is actually to say
help you know stop the nhs from being
overrun where it can
no longer cope and at the moment that is
based on
you know a couple of parameters numbers
of people over 60 with the disease
and the percentage of people in hospital
with coving and at the moment
they're manageable levels and if we need
to keep a much more
but we need better data on that which
isn't being provided
uh at more local level i've just got i
can only get the regional level at the
moment
and i think that's that would tell
people um
how to behave long term without these
big behavioral fluctuations and people
would
be able to plan things and and i think
that's a big difference and also
realizing that national lockdowns you
know effectively someone's worked out
that that cost the same as the whole nhs
budget for a month
so you could have doubled the year's
budget in the nhs
increased capacity and someone needs to
start thinking about the bigger picture
here about the pros and cons of doing
this stuff rather than
knee-jerk reactions because you know
suddenly deaths go up uh in one region
you know
overnight and i think that's that's
what's needed a longer-term view
using all the data and perhaps getting
you know people from different
disciplines
economists and uh other behavioral
scientists more involved in some of
these decisions
well let me bring you right up to date
then health secretary matt hancock said
this week that in some parts of england
there's a doubling of infections every
seven days and he used that stat to
justify
uh moving london and the southeast of
england into tier three
does the data justify that professor
our data doesn't no um but in like if
you take
london overall it's doubling every
uh month our last count but there are
some regions the northeast
where it is doubling every week or 10
days
but you can always post-hoc find data to
support
what's a decision and i think that's
generally what's what's happening here
and the question is do you lock down you
know
the decision was made to lock down nine
million people when in fact
uh there are these particular hot spot
areas
that are very alarming but that you know
there's a six-fold difference even in
london
between the rates of new infections so
it is complicated and i think people
need to find out what the
local data is in their area and if you
can stop people moving between
areas you know that should be doable so
i do think we need a
longer term approach to this that isn't
locking everything down
crippling the economy for areas that
have very low
uh levels of infection and i think you
know
that's the that's the big message here
this christmas in a way you do want
different rules for different areas
and i think um you know it may sound
unfair but that's the scientific uh
argument so on the basis of the data
you're gathering and then looking
forward
uh into january and february we
there are fears that i've referred to
that the christmas uh
easing up will lead to a spike or a
resurgence in cases
and then there is also a talk of a third
wave i think you have some views on that
yourself what does january february look
like to you
well i'm not as worried about seasonal
flu as james was
all the data show that we're at 10 of
the normal
uh rates of respiratory infections so it
just shows you that we can prevent
uh the normal colds and flus you know
i haven't had a cold all year it's fine
for a year it's fantastic
because we're not mixing we're not
mixing exactly
so we're not going to get a massive uh
influx of flu that was feared
and most people thought we would but
they haven't factored in our
amazing behavioral changes so i think
it's it's going to be
really all about uh covid uh
and if this will come in you know i
think we will get rid of this second
wave
um and i think there will be a lull and
we will see another one probably
uh in in february but i i believe it's
going to be less than
uh the first two a quarter of all the
infections are now coming from hospitals
and care homes
so if those staff are taken out of the
equation
then we won't be getting the deaths or
anything else so i i think uh things are
going to look up
the infection's still going to be around
but deaths and
the severe consequences will get better
so i've got a slightly more optimistic
message
for christmas if we all behave
[Music]
you